それでは時間がちょっと押しておりますけど
ご質問などありましたら
じゃあどうぞ  なぜ過去には戻らないのですか？なぜ過去には戻らないのですか？ なぜ過去には戻らないのですか？ 過去には戻らない
全部前もって前に前に前に進んでいくんだからね
過去に戻ったって意味がないでしょう
今更原始人になったって意味がある？え？ 原始人
なっても意味がないでしょうね
原始人  うん 未来人になるしかないでしょ
未来人になる  ん？ 未来人になるのは難しい
だって未来は来るんだから
やっぱ未来人でしょう
明日も未来だからね  明日は未来
今日はもう今日ではない
世界は現在しかない  そうそう
現在しか頑張るしかないんです
今は頑張る  うん？ 今は頑張るしかない
そうでしょう 今だけ頑張っちゃえばね
今はそんな高くないですよね
短いでしょうしね  じゃあもっと科学的に説明してください
何を [笑い]え？ さっき時間が戻らないかって言ったことを科学的に説明してください
科学的にね [笑い]では
自分の時計をもう元に戻ったらどうですかね
難しい  例えば時計を2時に戻す
時間2時になる？ならないでしょう
だから時間は戻りませんよ
勝手に思ったって時間は流れるだけ
流れるだけ  うん それ以上科学的な説明はありませんよ
では リンゴを 1個持って
これは元の木にするそうと
リンゴは現れる 生まれる
木から出てきたでしょ
どんどんどんどんの枝から
じゃあどんどん遡って木に戻ることできる？ どんどん遡って
リンゴを木にすることはできる？自分がどんどん遡って赤ちゃんになることはできる？できないでしょうに
だからそれだけの話でしょうに
毎日経験していることだから
それが科学的な説明なんです
それやってるから科学的な説明
事実っていうことなんです
科学的っていうのは フィクションじゃなくて事実
わかりました  うん はい
サンパジャンニャのもうちょっと聞きたいんですけど
そのサンパジャン サンパジャンニャの育て方とか
これ難しいんで説明は
サンパジャンニャの  なんか心から普通にそのヴィパッサナーを続けていくと自然に
例えば痛みを感じると
痛み痛み痛みと言うだけじゃなくて
痛みを経験もしながら
なんとなく微妙に理解もしながら
妄想しないで痛み痛みと言うんです
妄想しちゃうと もう理解じゃないんです
なんで痛いだろう あれやこれやではなくて
痛み痛みと言いながら
痛みそのものを経験して味わって理解していくんです
すごい微妙なんです  妄想しない
うん 妄想しないというだけじゃないんで
妄想しなくても何が起きてるかはっきり知ってるっていうこと
はい  あの 本当に俗っぽい質問なんですけれども
あの昨日 鳥のオリンピックで荒川さんが金メダルを取ってですね
あのテレビから新聞からもう一色に報道してですね
まるでもうオリンピックは金のためにあったみたいな報道で
あの長老の本の中に自責者慈悲記者の中でですね
まあ自分がオリンピックで金メダルを取ったら
自分がその人の気持ちになって喜んであげるという
そのムディターの気持ちは育てるべきだという風にありましたけれども
昨日のそのテレビの報道とかを見ますと
感動したじゃなくてですね
まあ喜怒哀楽の感情をですね
興奮を煽ってるだけのようなですね
報道に私には見えたんですけれども
長老の方にはどういうのを
だから私はあの子はね
見るとね もう見てまりましたからね
まあ金メダル取るぞとか
あれとか何な何のこともなく
ただ自分ももうもう何回も参加もしましたしね
ただ自分の仕事をやっただけ
そちらにはすごく落ち着きがあったんですね
それから妄想やら怒りやら欲やら見やら何もなかったんです
それは出るんだから 他の人の競技は見てないんだと
音楽も聴いてないんだと
だからいかに集中して落ち着いて
あまりも自我意識をしないで淡々とやれば完璧なものになるものかということをね
それで彼女はまた金メダルぶら下がってるのに
まだそうわかってないというかね
別にそんな目的なかったんだからね
あれすごいかっこよかったんでしょう
あの子の態度はね だから他みんな失敗でしょ
あの4回転回るって女の子がね
もう失敗しますね だから誰もやってないんだから
やってやる それだけでアウトになっちゃうんですよ
あの大舞台で だからあの彼女の精神状況を理解した方が一番いいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
それはなかったことにして
まあただ興奮して舞い上がっちゃって
それでいくらか儲かっちゃえばいいやということ
まあこれはもう単純に言えば
もう何て言いますか 寄生論理でしょうね
彼女の成功によってこちら寄生してなんとか
それは無自覚じゃないんです
素直にあ なるほど だから私はこのなんでこうなったのかという理性欲しいと言ったでしょ
前に その前に私はそういう風に見るんですよ
彼女のあの落ち着き それからはもうとにかく高い点数を出してやるぞという気持ちは0なし
他の人の点数も知らないっていう感じでね
あれが成功の道でしょう
貪瞋痴がなかったと思いますよ
その瞬間に 自我意識も自己中心的な思考もそれでなかったと思いますよ
ただ演技を出す それで肉体はくっとついてくるんです
心が落ち着いているんだから
そこをみんなで他の選手たちも学びましょうということがあった方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますよ
まあ一般人っていうのはまあ興奮してっていう
もう待ち構えていたんだから
誰か誰かをもうもう金メダル取ったら興奮するぞとかね
興奮するために待っていただけの話ですよ
まあそんなもんで  こんばんは
よろしいでしょうか 理性は因縁法則のことっていうところで
あ ヘレン  理性は因縁法則のことっていうところで
仏教の場合は善根を育てることが経験を深めることってあったんですけど
そこがちょっと理解が
善根を育てると 結果として良い
良い結果がついてくるということで
その因縁法則を理解していくっていう
だから あの まあ研究で言えば
いろんな資料を集めてデータを集めることと
データが揃ったところで
それはある論文に組み立てるということ
2つでしょ 論文に組み立てるためには因果法則が必要なんです
公式を理解するためにデータをっていうこと
公式級はすごいシンプルです
経験を深めるっていうのは
だから経験を深めれば深めるほど
また因果法則がわかってきますよ
例えば教習所で運転を習っただけで
ほとんど何もわからないでしょう
それで毎日運転すると
同じワンパターンの運転なんですけど
いろんな経験を深めて深めていって
なんとなくものすごく上手になるんですよ
そこで因果法則になるんですよ
善感情を育ってると 因果法則で良い結果が出ますよね
うん それによって因果法則っていうのはこういうことかっていう理解が深まるっていう
うん 全部お互いに絡み合ってますから
え？その過程でどこかで足が引っ張る
引っ張られると そこら辺でアブナイ人はそれを大体最初からの因果法則をわかっていたんだからって
全然因果法則になりません
しかし 普通の世界で因果法則の発見は今日説明しました
なんでこうなったのかとかね
別な答えはないのかとかね
そうやっていろいろシミュレーションやることなんです
それで我々の因果法則の過程はいくらかわかってきます
しかし 自分が幸福になりたいというのは一番基本だから
それで善感情から出てくると確実に幸福になるんだけど
なんでそうなったかとわからない場合はね
あんまり良くないんでしょうし
例えば慈悲を実践すると見事に良くなりますよ
環境も人間関係も自分の調子も
何でもかんでも仕事も全部うまくいくんですよ
あ 不思議だなと思っちゃうとダメなんです
これが 不思議だ 奇跡的だ
因果 慈悲の瞑想するとうまくいくんだとかね
嫌な人が笑ってくれたとかね
親切にしてくれたとかね
なんで不思議だろうとか
そう思っちゃうと もうバカ見所なんですよ
ではなくて 慈しみってどういうことかと
あ こういう原因でこういう結果という風に理解していかなくちゃいけないんです
それでは 個人的なことなんですけども
私の職場で すごい悪口を言う癖のある人がいて
それを聞いてしまうとどうしても嫌な気持ちになってしまいます
で それ怒りが出てしまうので
注意して 休憩して 怒りを消そうとしていたんですけども
それうまく注意できるときもあるような感じなんですが
そのことを意識して この人をなんか育てるような感じを最近してきて
それ自体の高さに仕上がってるんじゃないかなとも
その人が多分悪いと言うだろうなと警戒して
まずそこで  じゃあ座ってください
はい あの人の人の悪口を人が言って
その人を言う人の悪口を聞いて
自分がすごい気持ち悪くなったってことは
自分がそれを正しいとそのまま鵜呑みにしたっていうことなんです
この人言ってることは正しいんだと
合っているんだと 賛成しているんですよ
言ってることに賛成してないんだったら
これ人は喋ったっていいでしょう
何喋ったって あ そうあ
そう あ そうか これで終わっちゃうでしょ
まずそちら辺で自分の心の中でどうかで
それは賛成していて それからそれで自分で
これは悪いことだから自分で悩んでるんですね
だから人に人は自分の主観を言うのは迷惑なんですけど
みんなやってること だから人の言葉にまでかぎかけるっていうことは無理でしょうし
これはありえないでしょうしね
だから人はいろんなことを言うでしょうね
何言ったっても それはその人の主観であって
言葉にはそんなに真理性ってないんです
人が何かを言ったところで
それの真理性があるんだと思ったところで
自分の心の中に入るんでしょうに
だから何を心の中に入れて
何を心の中に入れないのかという
えーと あれも先感情の一つなんですけどね
分別能力 ダンマを教えてるんですけどね
それも我々は育てなくちゃいけないんです
このポイントなら なんか合ってるそうで
あ これは合ってないんだぞとかね
そういう風に分別能力で人の話を聞かなくちゃいけない
相手言うことはただのその人だけの考え方でね
その人の性格でとかだったらね
もう好きな放題言ってもいいでしょうに
相手が それでも自分が弱くて
好きな放題言わせちゃって
自分が全然聞いてないようにいることはできなかったら
まあ微妙に避けてもよろしいんです
気づかないように避けて
別に避けてるんだという気持ちはさせないというね
ただ悪口を言う機会は与えないとかね
会った時でも なんか突然自分が話題
別なこと あれやれこれやとか
知ってますか？イラフで大変なことになっているんだとかね
まだ冗談を言う能力がないんだからそうなるんですよ
結局 喜びを感じて冗談に言ってください
悪口の内容をもう決して自分では賛成していない
私ならどうするのかというと
ちょっと待ってくださいって
何かすぐメモを取って
はいはい どうぞ メモそれで終わりますけど
なんであんた だって大事なことでしょ？忘れたらあかんで
あの一生悪口言わないと思いますよ
その人 それぐらいのこと
だからやっぱりこれは私ならそうするんであってね
そちらはそちらなりに何とかふざけちゃえばいいっていうことですよ
別に大きな問題じゃないんです
それでもう 1つ言います
私の友達がいたんです
今ちょっと病気で 車椅子になっちゃったんですけど
まだ仕事はしているし
私よりは年下なんですけど
で この人 人はもう笑うことしか知らないというかね
もう怒ったりはしないんですね
何やってもなんか冗談を言うんです
そこである また友達というか
学校 大学の仲間が来てね
まあこの人に散々お世話になっているんです
むちゃくちゃ一方的にお世話になっているんですけど
ある日その友達がいない時はね
まあこの連中にもお金も今いろいろ入ってるんだからね
俺使ったっても使わせたってもいいじゃないんでしょうかと
そこを聞いたら これって友達かと
他の何？思ったんでしょうね
ただ あの自分の友達のところに泊まって
ご飯も食べてお世話になって
酒もいっぱい飲んで いや
もうどんどんお金使わせてやるぞというほかはどうでもいいやという態度っていうのはね
もう友達じゃないんですよ
しかし この肝心な友達はそれを知らないでいないところで言ったんだから
で 他の人々はそれを心配して
これ注意しなくちゃいけないんだと
それで本人に言ったんです
結局はあなたに寄生しているだけやと
この人は全然あなたのことを心配してないんだと
だからこんな必死で面倒見なくていいんじゃないか
適当でやってあげどうでしょうかと
あんなこと言う人っていうのは我々も気持ち悪いんだと
言ったら その友達の反応はね
だからとね 私はなんでこのその人にね
気持ち悪くなることをしなくちゃいかないんですかと
この人 私ともう腹が立つようなことをなぜしなくちゃいけないんでしょうかと
ということでしたからな
それはなるほどすごいなと
相手がもう悪友であることを知っているにも関わらず
悪友にはもう嫌な気持ちはさせないで置いておくと
まあ仲良ししましょうと
あんたが悪いと言ったら
向こうも気持ち悪くなっちゃって
それで何の利益があるのかという答えなんですね
だから役に立つか立たないかという理屈なんですけど
私は頭悪いくせに この人はすごくいい人生観を持ってる
私はずっともう 3 分喋ったら 4 分ぐらいお互い喧嘩してますよ
もう何とか言っても何か言いますからね
私はグタグタいろんなこと言うんだから
もうすごい 本人もそれすごい聞きたいんですね
まあいい人なんですけど
だから結局はいい人ですよ
だからこのいい人っていうのはそんなもんなんでしょうしね
だからそのエピソードにも答えがあると思いますけどね
その人は気持ち悪いなと思って
気持ち悪いことをあなたは表現しちゃうと
その人はあなたと腹が立つだけで
それであなたはあなたに何か利益あるのかと
何もないでしょ 結局 どうせ散々悪口言う人だから
もうもう何て言いますか
気持ちを引き締まって悪口言うようになっただけ
だからそういう原因を与えないことなんです
私もそういう人間はいましたけど
まあ人の足を引っ張るだけ
悪口言うだけ 嘘まで言って振りまき振りまいたりして
あ これっていうのはもう決まってここはもうここ
何て言いますか もうピッチブラックということで言いますけどね
もう黒いというね こんなピッチブラックブラックの性格っていうのはね
危ないから これって それで私は自分で
ではもう誰にね 悪口言って足を引っ張るんですけど
では私に対しても同じことをやるでしょうと
それはできないように私はどうすればよろしいかと
いわゆる逆にできればあなた
私の足も引っ張ってみてくださいという投資で仲良くしてみるんですよ
そこで見事に自分がすごい親切で
平等に区別分別なく差別なく
何でもかんでもやってあげたり
助けあげたりする その人はやっぱりみんなに迷惑かけるんですけど
私のことになってくるとやらないんです
それで私は一人では誰が勝ったんでしょうかね
だからあんたはもう悪人だと出ていけとかね
と言っても 相手が気持ち悪くなっても
さらに問題作るだけになります
いろいろそういうことでね
まあ第一 人をいうことは真面目に受け入れたそちらにちょこっと欠点があるんですね
それでも自分が弱いと思うならば
すごく賢く避けるんです
ただ避けた 避けただけではダメなんです
話したいんだけど 本当に申し訳ないとかね
先に行って断って帰るとかね
まあまあ 昼の時間とかね
本人がいろいろ言うんだったら
もう自分が先に行ってもう本当に今日はもういろいろ話したいこといっぱいあったんだけど
申し訳ない でも先にコマを打ったりとかね
そうすると本人避けてるんだとわからないんだからね
そういう風にこの賢く避けるんですよ
そういうことで頑張ってみてください
他にございますか  なんかなんか暗い時に本当に動きがいいのかと僕は思う時あるんですけど
動きは本当にいるんですか？ これが私がね
見たことないんだからね
現実には本当に  現実にはだから私がもう私も探してますよ
いるかないかどうかね
真面目な話 あのあなたと同じ年でね
私は夜お墓にも行ったことありますよ
一人で すごい怖いところで蛇もいるんです
ちょっとすごい怖かったんですけど
お化けがいるんだったら夜11時ぐらいでは出るでしょうと
出なかったんですよ じゃあダメだっていうこと
帰っちゃったんですから
だから私たちは実際に見てないんだったら
もういるかいないかわからない
まだわかっていない  ただ
暗い時は怖いだけ 暗いのは怖いっていうのはなんかまあおかしいんですけどね
例えばいきなりこの部屋が暗くなったら
あ 怖いって思ったって同じ部屋なんですけどね
そういうことは お化けの話やらあれこれの話になるんですよ
冷たいとかっていう時は
うん これはもう誰にでもありますからね
例えば今いっぱい音あるでしょ？すっごく夜になってくると
2時ぐらい  3時ぐらいになってくると
人の音が全部なくなるでしょうに
その時は建物やらもう梁やら何でもかんでも冷たいんだから縮むでしょ
縮んじゃうとジリジリジリジリとかね
いろんな音が出るんです
私の部屋では大体 3時になったら誰か何かドアを叩くように
トントントン トントントン
ずっとその音はあるんでしょうね
まず全然わからないんです
どこから音が来るのかと思ったら
この窓の上にちっちゃなガラス 1枚があって
これはガタガタしてるんですよ
だからもう音は来るものも何もないんだから
ちょこっと空気が風が吹いただけで
あのガラスがカタカタカタカタする
それをちゃんと人がなんかドアを叩いてるような感じで聞こえるんですよ
子供がいたらもう漏らしちゃうかな
どうも まあそんなもんで
まあ人間妄想して怖くなるんです
あ？ もし連れて行かれたらどうしよう
それで行ったらそれ行けばいいでしょ
でも連れて行かれたら
でも一緒に行くんだけど
私にはこれが欲しい プレイステーションが欲しいとかね
よく言ってもいいんです
本当にいいかわかってない
本当にいいか今はわかっていない
だから我々にわからないということは
我々に関係ないということなんです
関係がない  うん 連れて行かれません
行かれません  関係ないんだから知らないんです
関係ないからこそ知らない
うん そういうことで まあ一緒に行こうって言ったら
まあプレイステーションでも買ってくるならば行きますよと
はい あまり長い時間喋るとね
まあ今まで話の途中で気付いた
気付けられたことがない方々まで気づくかもしれませんだから
まあそこら辺で話を終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
では こうのものを唱えますが
こうの門 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝奉仕
界の守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
功徳によって すべての人々生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そしてお経があげられます
サッビーティオーリバイジャントサッブロウゴウビナッセットマーテーラワーヨスキーディーガユクブハウェーバハトゥサッバマンガランラックハントサッバデーヴ
ァタサッバブッダーヌバーヴェーナサッバダンマーヌバーヴェーナサッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダーサッティバワントテーアビワダナシーリッサーニッチャンワッ
ダパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーワッダンティーヤーユワンノースカンバラン
では どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます